foreign
[Music]
[Music]
's co-stars are not wrong the actress is
literally shining so bright her net
worth is reportedly in the 15 to 20
million dollar range and while her
salary isn't known for Euphoria Zendaya
reportedly earned 2 million for
Spider-Man no way home see I don't know
about anybody else here but I was
terrified yes because you know you just
want to you want to prove that you're
worth being a part of the next
Spider-Man
Zendaya is also in another major
franchise Dune and while her part in the
First installment got her an estimated
300 000. expect her to get paid a lot
more for the second as her character
Shawnee plays a much bigger role kind of
being able to pop in at the last minute
and um have some very special scenes
that kind of set up what we possibly
could be in the future
um
it's been really exciting and while it
seems Zendaya is doing all right for
herself financially she did admit in an
interview with British Vogue she would
love to quote have a career where you
can be in a position financially to just
do things you want to do because you
enjoy the work and not have to worry
about the other things and what's the
most Luxe thing that you've ever worn
it's actually a funny story
um I went to a Premiere and I had these
earrings they were big beautiful
earrings I thought they were fake to be
honest with you and then there was this
article that came out the next day that
was like Zendaya where's a million
dollar earrings and I was like law did
you put me in million dollar earrings
last night he's like probably no they're
not mine I gave them back she might not
own those million dollar earrings but
Zendaya's fashion game is always on
point who can forget these Thirty one
thousand dollar spider web earrings so
that's beyond as for her digs she showed
off her luxurious backyard of her 1.4
million dollar starter home to Vogue
back in 2019 but now the the star lived
in a four million dollar home in Encino
California and Zendaya doesn't just
bring in money from movies and TV she's
also done deals with Lancome Tommy
Hilfiger and SmartWater to name a few
whatever the choice just keep it smart
if I try to take the world out of it and
it's not about proving anything to the
world but it's really about getting
better as an artist that's a much
happier place to work from when you're
working just to really just to prove
yourself that you can do it
[Music]